torches human rights violations
absolutely awful things that happened
under Russian occupation well I looked
at my phone and there was missed calls
from the office and so I called them and
they obviously wanted me to be on live
as soon as possible and my first
reaction was I'm not going outside
people ran because they heard the sirens
this lady has just come to work and has
realized that there's no work because
there's war and I became very confident
that this was a massive Bluff and that
it wasn't going to happen and absolutely
unjustified brutal and horrific
invasion of a sovereign country
my name is Gulliver Craig I'm English I
was born in London but I started my
journalistic career basically in France
um working first of all for English
language French radio and then for
France 24. three years in Paris working
in the office there I moved to Poland
first of all whereas correspondent
working for the French and English
channels and my zone as it were of
coverage was Poland Ukraine Hungary and
Belarus and that was now 12 years ago
and I still
still doing the same job except that in
2014 because of everything that was
happening in Ukraine I moved to Ukraine
and so Kiev became my base but I still
was you know traveling around these four
countries all the time I had been
covering Ukraine since 2010 the first
report that I did about Ukraine was the
election campaign for the 2010 election
when niana kovich won in a more or less
free and fair election and after that I
was following the development of the
yanakovich presidency and very much
aware of the increasing levels of
corruption and the fears that there were
of authoritarian drift and so we were
like rooting for the ukrainians
absolutely like when the maidan first
started we were like get rid of these
bastards who've reneged on their promise
to sign the association agreement with
the European Union I was throughout that
year 2013 I was following the
developments of the
potential signing of that Association
agreement I did a report about it in
August when the Russians first I think
they closed the border and or made it
very difficult for Ukraine to export to
Russia in order to put pressure if you
remember you know so I was I was really
following it and thinking it would be so
amazing if people protested against this
terrible behavior of the anakovich
government and oppressive from the
Russians and I didn't believe it would
happen and then it did happen and we
were super excited
[Music]
at the beginning of the maidan protest
we were like wow you know come on guys
we're really surprised and pleased to
see so many people coming out into the
streets to protest because we thought
that it was we I'm saying me and most of
my other Western journalist friends you
know thought that it was absolutely
right to protest against this government
because it was clearly stealing money
from the Ukrainian people in huge
quantities
I'd been in 2013 in the beginning of the
year actually I did a report in donbath
about the copenkey and how
um as it turned out
I don't think we were able to completely
prove it but it seemed pretty clear that
Alexander Yanukovych Victor yanakovich's
son was taking a huge uh percentage of
money from this illegal mining which is
illegal and also extremely dangerous and
it really felt like you know the mafia
was running the country and so when the
modern practice started we were super
pleased that people were protesting and
standing up for their rights I did see
protesters trying to resist the column
of Riot police that was pushing them
away from their demonstration in front
of the government offices about a
kilometer away from Independent Square
here earlier on at the moment though the
police have not started trying to
dismantle the barricades that are
actually surrounding Independence Square
the epicenter of the protest but they
are on the edges of the square to be
seen and uh the word that's been given
to the protesters from people speaking
on the stage is to be as nice to the
police as you possibly can go and offer
them a cup of tea tell them that you're
sorry that it's so cold and try to
really put the emphasis on the fact that
this is a peaceful demonstration I think
everybody is really wanting to see
what's going to happen and really
anxious to see how this is going to end
and when it's going to end
um but if it descends into some kind of
Frozen conflict and things aren't
changing it's quite hard to keep
people's interests because there are
lots of other things in the world going
on that are changing and that take
priority and there's only a certain
amount of stories that people can that
media can have in their in their
bulletins so I don't know but at the
moment that really doesn't look like
happening right I don't see any
um freezing of this conflict or even
kind of uh simmering down to the like
low level low intensity conflict that
there was in donbath for all those years
I don't see that happening at the moment
and so I don't think that interest is
going to fade
[Music]
it was in London for Christmas when I
had my darkest thoughts about how I
thought that he was really going to go
ahead with it put in I kind of worked
out a logic that
he had come to the conclusion that
ukrainians would never again vote for a
pro-russian government
and he had been up until this point
hoping Putin that some medwich type
character would eventually be elected
president of Ukraine and he'd be able to
control Ukraine that way
and that if he had come to the
conclusion that it could not be done by
political manipulation and he could not
accept the idea of Russia losing control
of Ukraine then he would definitely try
to do it by force I remember in London
having conversations with people there
who were very incredulous and thinking
of course you wouldn't really do it you
know when I was the guy there saying no
I really think he might you know I
really think he might and then in
January I can't remember what I read or
who I talked to or what made me change
my mind but I started to think that
Putin must know that this would
ultimately be a disaster for him and
therefore this whole thing must be that
he's bluffing that he's trying to really
threaten this use of force in order to
get what he wants in Ukraine somehow in
order to get the US to kind of decide
that they don't want to back Ukraine in
fact that it's not worth it or whatever
it's not worth the risk and that this is
all the massive Bluff and I became very
confident that this was a massive Bluff
and that it wasn't going to happen and I
stuck to this kind of view until the
speech on when was it 21st of February
when he recognized the DNR and lnr and
then I then I knew obviously from that
point it was clear that they were going
to attack but even then I thought maybe
they were just attacking Don bass that's
what a lot of Ukrainian experts were
saying that they would attack in on bass
and try to destabilize the country with
cyber attacks elsewhere I was still kind
of surprised on the 24th of February
when like right away they were attacking
not only Kiev but Targets in Western
Ukraine as well
[Music]
I looked at my phone and there was
missed calls from the office and so I
called them and they obviously wanted me
to be on live as soon as possible and my
first reaction was I'm not going outside
because there's I can hear explosions so
I said okay but by Skype from indoors
you know and I think I did one or two
lives from uh indoors by Skype and
just based on what I was you know
reading on online basically and
and then they then they said do you
think you could maybe go out into the
street and I was like okay realizing
that probably it wasn't really so
dangerous in the center of Kiev and then
I did some lives in the street and then
it was you know there was people walking
in the street yeah it was quite
bewildered just like everyone around you
know it was kind of there's people
walking around maybe I could speak to
them to see what they're saying and it
seemed really odd to go up to people
thinking that I know what you're
thinking but I kind of have to ask you
what you're thinking in order to be able
to quote you in some way and I asked a
couple of people and basically all that
day I was doing live reports right
all the time
there was one that I remember outside
this Museum on Bogdana Wellness cover
Street I can't remember what it is the
Museum of but um
a lady had come to work
um who worked at the Museum and I guess
she hadn't heard the explosions and I
guess she didn't have internet on her
phone or wasn't listening to the radio
or anything so she came to work and
found it to be closed and only then like
looked up what was going on and found
out you know and so I was able to tell
this story in my life that was right
next to me there's this lady who's just
come to work and has realized that
there's no work because there's war and
I went to the bus station because people
were fleeing
and there I did a little bit of filming
filmed some interviews with people who
were waiting for buses and then the
sirens went off first time I heard the
sirens and people run people ran there
was crowds at the bus station near the
railway station and people ran because
they heard the sirens and uh I
unfortunately didn't hold my camera and
film them as they ran in order to get
the image I also was scared and ran
first time you hear the sirens you don't
know what it means so you kind of to my
mind it like made me immediately think
of something like the Blitz in London
where there's planes flying over and
dropping bombs completely
indiscriminately you know after a while
you come to realize that most of the
time in a place like Kiev if there's a
siren it means there's a missile that's
probably heading for some kind of
infrastructure Target and if you're not
near I mean obviously you need to you
know there's doesn't mean you
necessarily need to run for cover right
away
um and at that time I did though I just
ran for cover and then I spoke to a taxi
driver saying what do you think I should
do shall I uh I need to edit this stuff
which I filmed but maybe I should just
go and hide and stuff and it was like
you'd probably like be all right if you
just drive home and uh and I did yeah
and I'm sure that nowadays if there's a
siren goes off and people are at the bus
station it's no way the kind of movement
of the crowd suddenly like running away
like there was on that first day because
everybody was in the same situation that
they were like experiencing this for the
very first time
[Music]
objectivity is also means that you have
to you know recognize that the
ukrainians are also engaged in an
information war and they might not
always think that telling the truth is
their best strategy and they might be
right in thinking that telling the truth
is not always their best strategy but
you as a journalist have to you know
bear that in mind and you you have to be
telling the truth but telling the truth
is also you know it's very much and I
also find it's often in my case a little
bit of correcting the presenters in
Paris who will uh tend to especially
because of the way it's reported you
know by Reuters and AFP say the Russians
say this uh there are you know and I I I
find myself sometimes on air saying well
you know the Russians say this but think
of all the things the Russians have said
which turned out to be completely not
true so I don't know without any
evidence of this coming from anywhere
else than the Russians say this I don't
think we shouldn't um
uh you know I don't think there's any
reason to think that it's true but I
also think that the general principle of
Ukraine being the country that has truth
on its side is really worth Ukrainian
officials bearing in mind and that
sometimes uh telling the truth about
something uh that is reflects badly on
Ukraine in some way may be worth it for
them for the sake of maintaining The
credibility because at the moment
Ukraine has a much higher level of
credibility than Russia but it doesn't
have top perfect credibility right it's
certainly like people journalists are
aware that you can't necessarily take
what Ukrainian officials say as face
value and I kind of would encourage the
ukrainians to think that it's really
worth having the reputation of being the
guys who tell the truth but I also
sometimes think that that's a little bit
of a naive position for me to have as a
Westerner
not naive maybe but uh naive's not the
web but I also sometimes think that's a
bit of a utopian uh position for me to
have uh Anton hirachinko the other day
tweeted about this yeah but but look how
many people retweet him and look how
many Western journalists because he's so
helpful to us it's like I don't know
most western journalists I guess didn't
know him before I've known him
I've known who he is for a long time
I've met him a few times and I kind of
know that he's not a very trustworthy
guy but he's also lately very helpful in
giving you contacts and trying to like
get access for journalists and stuff so
you feel kind of grateful to him and
then perhaps that makes people more
inclined to retweet things that he
tweeted but the other day he tweeted
about these uh protests in Moscow about
Moscow City Center being closed off did
you see this it was complete light I
think yeah and then everybody was like
there's no reports this is the only
source so yeah
um but thousands of people including
journalists
um you know retweeted it unquestioningly
and you know you really got to be
careful of things like that
foreign
[Music]
with Reuters I think there's a problem
and I think maybe there's a problem that
is to do with the agreement that they
had with Tas
I tend to think that most of the time
it's due to sloppiness
and people not thinking rather than some
kind of uh deeper pro-russian narrative
that they're trying to push in any kind
of deliberate way I guess there's a bit
of a feeling I have at the moment that
everyone's attention has turned to
what's going on on the military front
what's going on in her song A and B the
long-range attacks on Ukrainian
infrastructure the power cuts and
everything and that has probably
distracted attention from the Torches
human rights violations absolutely awful
things that happened under Russian
occupation particularly in hark if
obelis because now so much of that has
been revealed and I think probably yeah
that there should be more attention on
that because in a way the world's eyes
moved on too quickly
um
but probably if you look up for stories
about that there are Stories being
generated every day about it they're
just not getting the top headlines
because people's attention is focused on
the the latest development I do worry
about how to make each report different
from one another you know I mean you
already saw they they
uh liberated his zoom and they found all
the graves of the people who'd been
killed and it was a huge Story look how
many International media were there it
was almost like a media circus it was
really quite hard to even film without
having journalists in your shot and
everything because everybody was there
they also discovered I think 120 graves
in liman
similarly unclear how these people died
similarly exhuming them in order to
investigate and that didn't get nearly
as much attention because people think
okay well it's basically the same on the
other hand it's like the one also needs
to find a way to make people realize
they're not the volume of this the scale
of this that there was 400 and something
just outside the zoom 120 something in
liman and there are other sites that
have been found and you need to be able
to cover these things and to make
reports about them in order to for
people to realize they're full scale
that it's not Justice one burial site in
his room that was found a body is pulled
from its grave and the criminologist
Begins the examination
first the clothes civilian
soon it becomes apparent that the man
has injuries to his genital area
[Music]
he beckons a colleague to take a look
they're clearly disturbed by what they
see
due to the rotten stairs of the body
examination suspended
that's it it's enough really yeah
sometimes I think we as journalists
think okay well I've done that
um I'm not going to do it again and I
think actually sometimes you just have
to think well yeah I'm going to do it
again I'm going to make a report which
is going to be very similar to the one
that I made in his room but we have to
do it because this is what's happening
and probably lots and lots of people did
not watch the first report that you made
and so they won't be thinking you're
just repeating yourself and also you can
find obviously different different words
to tell the same story and different
pictures so you can try to be a bit more
specific right you can say something
like
out of a thousand homes in his um X
thousand are considered not rebuildable
or something to be a bit more precise
and sometimes you have to dig out a bit
more information in order to say
something more precise rather than just
saying the kind of cliched phrase that
the town is in Ruins ever since uh this
uh whole movement started Molly
ukrainians have been coming up to us as
foreign journalists here in Kiev and
Thanking us for being here and drawing
attention to the situation and asking
again and again the same question when
is Western Europe good to introduce
sanctions they've been calling her for
that for weeks there have also been
pickets calling for sanctions ukrainians
care very very much about whether the
world is watching and whether the world
will act
foreign
[Music]
that there is a stronger and stronger
consolidation of a pro-ukrainian
position among the French Elites and you
know you're talking about the French
center right
um goalist political Elites people like
Francois fion who ran for president and
was defeated by macron when however many
years ago 2017. you know these are
people with close ties to Russia and
traditionally Jacques Shirak the former
president was a guy who you know liked
to develop good relations with Russia
Catherine Colona who's now the foreign
minister was foreign minister under
Shirak and I think that these are people
who've kind of gone on a journey from
you know changing their attitudes to
Russia and realizing that they just
aren't going to be able to get anything
out of trying to have
good relations or any kind of diplomatic
relations with Vladimir Putin's regime
and so I think that their support for
Ukraine is getting stronger but I'm like
totally not an expert on French ticks
and I don't really know I mean in terms
of public opinion you've got the
anti-American left in France who are
just instinctively wanting to see
something bad and something to blame
America for and who will try to go for
their sort of well yes
um
of course Russia is bad but America is
bad too they shouldn't have expanded
NATO and all of this rubbish and don't
realize how much they're just parroting
Russian propaganda about this and stuff
but I just try to avoid those people to
be honest I was invited to speaker
um
a uh on over Skype it was like in March
they had a little uh they had a
screening of a film about the holodomor
that film um uh not very good film
agnesco Holland did
um what's it called Mr Jones
[Music]
after excuse me
local Cinema in France people I know
these are very kind of left-wing people
they run these kind of alternative
European Cinema type things and they
asked me to speak and so and then the
the people were asking me questions of
course about Ukrainian nationalists and
how strong are Ukrainian far-right
nationalists and these kinds of
questions you know and I answered them
like saying you've really got to stop
seeing these Ukrainian nationalists in
the same way as you see French
nationalists because French nationalists
are people who are racist and
anti-immigration and it's a nationalism
of of hate you know and Ukrainian
nationalism is the nationalism of
Defending Your Country because your
country's under attack and however much
you want to agree with them or not you
really have to see that there's a really
important difference here and they were
all like oh wow that was such an
important point it was like they were
really like they really like this answer
and said it really made them think I
think that like a lot of people in
Western Europe had a certain sort of
wariness about anything that seems like
Ukrainian nationalism because they
compare it to their own nationalisms in
their own countries which are much more
about you know being racist
authoritarian and anti-democratic
anti-european you know the fact that in
Ukraine you can be a nationalist and
pro-european is like oh wow what's this
you know in Western Europe they need to
like have a think a little bit in order
to understand
[Music]
in terms of broader understanding of the
country the easy mistake to make which
loads of journalists make is that
there's like a russian-speaking minority
in this country who are in danger of
being in some way repressed by the
Ukrainian speakers and what people need
to realize that it's more the Ukrainian
speakers in Ukraine who felt like they
were oppressed who felt like they had to
feel embarrassed to speak their own
language for years and years and years
and even now uh you know only just now
it's beginning to be that you know
people don't feel sort of looked down
upon for speaking Ukrainian and it's
like a really long journey that the
Ukrainian language is on and it's
positive discrimination that is going on
in terms of discriminating in favor of
the Ukrainian language and they're also
a huge proportion of Russian speakers in
Ukraine would be very happy if their
children spoke Ukrainian and so the
whole like language Dynamic and conflict
around that is it's not that it's like a
non-issue in Ukraine some people like
come to Ukraine and get told that it's a
non-issue it's not like it's a non-issue
in my view but it's an issue that people
need to understand in like a pretty much
the other way around than the way lots
of people who come with kind of
um you know basic ideas about how these
things usually work
um understand it
[Music]
I think probably most of the civilized
Democratic Western world is rooting for
Ukrainian Victory I think that that was
what how most people would feel
comfortable with putting it that way
because even when you are attached to
the principle of objectivity here we are
looking at an objective situation where
Ukraine whatever it spots whatever its
problems did not deserve to be invaded
this was completely unprovoked Invasion
and this is something that everybody
should be really standing together to
fight against and I think that you can
perfectly well be a journalist sticking
to the principle of objectivity and of
telling the truth whilst also being
quite clear about the fact that
um you know we're not on Russia's side
here there's only a few of us foreign
correspondents who live here the whole
time unlike lots of people who are
coming in and visiting and I think for
us who live here it's that much more
traumatic not as traumatic as for people
who are actually Ukrainian but to some
degree you know it's also really really
hard and while some people might be
coming here and finding this exciting or
just interesting and good for their
careers I don't feel like that I just
feel like I just really really want it
to end and I don't mind saying also that
I really want it to end with the
Ukrainian Victory and then to be
covering stories about the
Reconstruction of this country and I
don't think it's a contradiction with
wanting to be objective and stick to
telling the truth as a journalist to be
clear in this case whose side we're on
because clearly this was you know just
an absolutely unjustified brutal and
horrific
invasion of a sovereign country and also
what the Russian armed forces are doing
here just is just absolutely shocking
and awful and of course we all want it
to end as soon as possible
foreign
[Music]
on the trains they're so comfortable I
love the very very strong instant coffee
in the morning and also I mean I already
loved Lucas Ellis and it's here before
the war but now I just think that they
have been absolute heroes in evacuating
people and keeping the trains running
even when it's dangerous even when the
power supply is cut I came back I went
to Poland for the weekend and I came
back on the train from helm
on Tuesday morning
as we were coming into Kiev Kiev with uh
I think there was a um error on at the
time when the train was coming into Kiev
and throughout the night there had been
several across Ukraine the train was not
even on time it was three minutes early
how did they do it in England if there's
like if the temperature Falls below zero
or above 30 the trains don't run because
they say the weather conditions don't
permit it you know in Ukraine it's just
unbelievable how how they managed to
keep everything going